et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Bruno Retailleau je vous en prie
installez-vous bonjour
président du groupe les républicains au
Sénat on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse régionale représentée par
Julien Lecuyer La Voix du Nord bonjour
Julien bonjour Oriane bonjour monsieur
on a évidemment beaucoup d'actualités à
voir avec vous Bruno Retailleau mais on
commence par ce qui s'est passé au Sénat
hier et cette audition de la ministre
Marlène Schiappa auditionnée par la
commission d'enquête sénatoriales sur le
fond Marianne alors la ministre a dit
vouloir assumer la responsabilité
politique des décisions prises est-ce
qu'elle vous a convaincu non pas
vraiment ce que je veux dire quand même
c'est que moi je suis assez fier d'être
sénateur quand on regarde les
commissions d'enquête qui sont menées
par le Sénat quand on regarde la propos
des questions le professionnalisme la
précision chirurgicale des questions je
comprends que les ministres les hauts
fonctionnaires n'aiment pas bien ce
genre d'exercice pour le reste qu'est-ce
que nous dit cette entretien cette
audition d'abord que Marlène Chapa a de
l'aplomb mais qu'elle a pas toute la
réponse parce que c'est des fossés quand
c'était pas l'administration c'était son
cabinet mais elle n'a pas répondu à une
contradiction quelle est la
contradiction fondamentale puisque toute
sa défense est de dire je ne me suis
occupé de rien et pour autant
elle avait des collaborateurs proches
dans le comité de sélection et surtout
elle a elle-même écarté un dossier de
SOS Racisme donc c'est difficile de dire
je dis suis pour rien je ne me souviens
plus c'est la faute de mon
administration du cabinets mais surtout
j'ai pas mis la main alors que si elle a
mis la main pour écarter un dossier donc
elle aurait mis la main pour écarter un
dossier est-ce que elle a mis la main
pour favoriser d'autres dossiers c'est
toute la question que nous devons douter
encore de sa parole hier
oui bien sûr il y a des doutes il y a
des doutes pourquoi parce qu'il y a une
contradiction c'est tout ce doute cette
incertitude moi je veux pas juger les
gens je veux dire qu'avant qui puisse
apporter des preuves avant qu'il puisse
s'expliquer mais cette contradiction
hier elle ne l'a pas levée
le fiasco contre la lutte pour dans la
lutte contre l'islamisme
tout à fait tout à fait vous savez que
hier le Sénat la conférence est
président a pris une décision importante
puisque nous avons décidé de créer une
commission d'enquête sur le drame de
Samuel Paty à la suite de la saisine du
président du Sénat par la soeur de
Samuel Paty à la suite d'un livre
d'enquête d'investigation
qui est paru Stephen Simon qui est paru
il y a quelques semaines bien sûr vous
avez l'objectif c'est une étude
l'objectif c'est d'éclairer les
conditions dans lesquelles
les services de l'éducation nationale
les services de sécurité ont protégé ou
non
Sammel Patty il y a une enquête pour
répondre à la question de Julien lucuyer
que peu de gens ont vu de l'Ifop qui
fait ce genre d'enquête régulièrement
auprès d'enseignants cette enquête telle
date du 9 décembre 2022 donc je suis
précis que nous dit cette enquête elle
nous dit essentiellement deux choses
1 la décapitation de salopatie n'a servi
à rien pourquoi parce que après cette
décapitation 5 des enseignants 56%
déclarent qu'ils s'autocensure pour
éviter des incidents avant la
décapitation c'était 36% donc il y a une
augmentation du phénomène d'autocensure
des enseignants et 77% près de 80 % des
enseignants déclare que le ministère
leur propre ministère n'a pas tiré les
leçons de la décapitation de ce
myopathie donc la commission d'enquête
doit éclairer
l'environnement dans lequel a pu se
produire cette décapitation ça c'est un
premier point mais l'autre point ce sera
de dire est-ce que l'éducation nationale
est toujours dans ne pas de vagues
est-ce qu'elle protège ses enseignants
on voit la multiplication des abayas on
voit mais mais le vide le vide des
réponses que nous fait monsieur
papendial de semaine en semaine quand on
le questionne sur ce sujet là sur les
abayas les camis etc donc il y a un vrai
souci des atteintes à nécessité qui se
multiplient et donc cette commission
d'en-tête doit éclairer comment
fonctionne l'éducation nationale
j'imagine mais c'est pas moi de faire le
programme des auditions c'est une
commission d'enquête c'est assez
original puisque on crée d'abord une
mission d'information qui va réunir les
deux commissions qui sont compétentes
sur l'aspect sécurité l'aspect éducation
nationale la commission des lois
François nalbuffet président et la
commission culture donc Laurent et puis
quand on aura mis ensemble si j'ose dire
ces deux commissions elles vont se
transformer en commission d'enquête et
les présidents les deux présidents que
je viens de vous citer seront en même
temps les deux rapporteurs donc début
des travaux après les sénatoriales où
vous souhaitez que ça débute
assez rapidement mais on a 6 mois le
délai le délai c'est six mois donc les
conclusions sont attendues dans six mois
avec une proposition de loi probable
après on verra c'est tout n'est pas dans
la loi il faut perdre je sais en France
on pense qu'un problème égal la solution
une loi non non si sinon on est le pays
des lois c'est la traduction des deux
idéogrammes chinois fagots en chinois la
France le pays des lois non tout ne se
résout pas dans les lois on a tellement
de loi d'ailleurs qu'on a on résout
aucun autre problème général de
l'Éducation nationale du mammouth comme
disait un ancien ministre où il y a un
problème pas peine il y a un problème
direct depuis le départ on le sait il a
un rapport avec le modèle républicain
français qui est un rapport beaucoup
plus inspiré du modèle anglo-saxon
américain je vous rappelle que il avait
écrit quand même être français être
français
c'est avec quelque chose à voir avec la
race la couleur voilà être noir c'est
être d'ailleurs être français c'est être
blanc c'était ces mots c'est absolument
stupéfiant qui a eu le Macron d'ailleurs
les nomber voilà mais il y a aussi un
problème avec l'Éducation nationale avec
l'institution le pas de vagues comment
est-ce que l'institution qui doit être
le lieu l'école je le redis
quand on parle de laïcité le lieu qui
doit écarter tout atteinte c'est bien
l'école parce qu'on forme des jeunes
conscience et s'il y a bien un lieu qui
doit respecter strictement les critères
de laïcité c'est l'école c'est la raison
pour laquelle ma famille politique a
fait voter en 2004 l'interdiction des
signes son tatouage religieux et cette
loi de 2004 et n'est pas seulement
valable pour le foulard tapendial
devrait savoir elle est aussi valable
pour les tenues longues qui sont des
tenues ostentatoires par lequel on
manifeste non seulement une appartenance
mais on fait aussi du prosélytisme et
vous souhaitez qu'Emmanuel Macron change
de ministre de l'éducation nationale on
parle de la remaniement qui serait
imminent je verrai mais c'est un des
maillons faibles
est-ce que c'est un maillon faible
aujourd'hui c'est un maillon faible mais
je ne demande jamais la démission des
ministres même après son audition je
demande jamais pour deux raisons il y a
des professionnels de la demande de la
démission dire que toutes les semaines
ils ont une demande de démission et
alors après non moi c'est pas mon rôle
c'est pas ma responsabilité elle
appartient à cette responsabilité au
président de la République deuxième
chose moi je ne condamne pas les gens
avant d'avoir des preuves voilà c'est
tout je pense qu'aujourd'hui il y a un
processus qui doit éclairer les
conditions dans lesquelles les choses
ont eu lieu et je vous rappelle
d'ailleurs que tout ça intervient après
la décapitation de Samuel Baptiste c'est
la raison pour laquelle les choses sont
quand même assez graves dans le collège
ne porte toujours pas son nom
contrairement à la promesse d'Emmanuel
Macron comment vous l'expliquez je
l'explique par le comment dirais-je par
le rapport d'Emmanuel Macron de la
macronie à la laïcité il y a un petit
problème parce que je pense que ils sont
sur un modèle diversitaire beaucoup plus
que républicain le modèle républicain
c'est l'universalisme c'est l'intention
vis-à-vis la comment dirais de la
laïcité le modèle anglo-saxon c'est la
cohabitation des communautés c'est nous
nous sommes pas une société
communautariste voilà et Emmanuel Macron
a beaucoup beaucoup varié notamment dans
ces prises de position et là le fait
qu'on soit pas capable de nommer un
collège du nom de Samuel Paty révèle
quelque chose de grave
hier lors des questions d'actualité au
Sénat il y a eu plusieurs questions sur
le drame de Nancy la semaine dernière
sur cette agression au couteau Elisabeth
borne la première ministre elle a parlé
de ceux qui avaient réagi trop vite
après le drame d'Annecy est-ce que vous
êtes senti visé pas du tout moi j'en ai
marre voyez quand nous interdise de
prendre la parole pour dénoncer ce qui
s'est passé moi j'ai vécu si j'ose dire
dans ma chair j'ai perdu quelqu'un que
j'estimais beaucoup c'était il y a deux
ans il était prêt tout près de chez moi
je le connaissais bien le Père Olivier
maire il a été assassiné par un migrant
qui était d'ailleurs catholique bon ce
migrant c'était ma tenu pendant plus de
10 ans irrégulièrement sur le territoire
français il est attrapé par trois
obligations de quitter le territoire il
avait incendié la cathédrale de Nantes
et il était profondément troublé sur le
plan psychologique il n'était donc
expulsé trois au qtf il n'était pas en
prison il avait brûlé pourtant la
cathédrale de Nantes et n'était pas un
hôpital psychiatrique ça commence à
faire beaucoup quand même le drame de
Nancy ce drame de Saint-Laurent sur
scène Lola etc etc et à chaque fois
c'est la même chose on n'en tire pas les
conséquences on veut nous réduire en
silence moi je dis que l'un des sens
justement celle-ci lance parce
qu'évidemment quelques jours après on en
parle déjà beaucoup moins donc les coups
de gueule ça sert à quelque chose
ce matin dans Le Figaro elle y répond
elle dit nous voulons lutter contre
l'immigration illégale éloignée plus
rapidement ce qui n'ont pas être sur
notre territoire et mieux intégrer ce
que nous accueillons on doit pouvoir se
retrouver avec les républicains elle n'a
pas raison non aucune regardez par
exemple
il faut changer de cadre il faut une loi
de rupture vous savez que on a un peu
plus de 20 ans il y a eu 21 lois 21 lois
ça n'a rien changé ce que nous nous
demandons ce que nous avons proposé
c'est une rupture c'est vraiment une
régulation mais très puissante elle que
dit-elle par exemple sur une des pompes
inspirantes aspirantes que le texte de
Gérald Darmanin voudrait à nouveau créer
pour régulariser de façon systématique
les clandestins qui sont sur le sol
français clandestin donc illégaux sur
les métiers en tension elle veut
simplement en discuter les modalités
nous disons pas un premier pas pour vous
mais c'est non nous avons je le redis je
n'irai même pas discuté les modalités
avec elle je devrais recevoir dans
quelques jours Gérald Darmanin notre
porte est ouverte moi je veux le bien de
mon pays je suis dans l'opposition mais
on a montré sur les retraites et sur
beaucoup d'autres choses que ce qui nous
guide c'est pas l'antimachronisme c'est
pas la politique politicienne on veut
régler les points qui sont les points
douloureux pour patriote donc moi je
recevrai simplement on ajoutera pas une
autre pompe aspirante Didier leski c'est
pas moi il est haut fonctionnait il
dirige l'Office français de
l'immigration d'intégration il a fait un
livre il y a deux ou trois ans le Grand
Dérangement il dit voilà la France c'est
le pays le plus avantageux pas spirante
sur le droit d'asile sur leur groupement
familial sur les soins gratuits pour les
clandestins sur la nature et avion alors
quatre bons passe-pirantes et on en
ajoute une cinquième mais vous savez
mais concrètement ça veut dire monsieur
Retailleau qu'il n'y a pas de voix de
passage à l'heure actuelle pour ce texte
est-ce qu'on doit clairement
se préparer à un 49-3 alors il y a une
voix de passage si le gouvernement
reprend notre texte notamment la loi
ordinaire avec des principes plus de
pompe aspirantes on entre pas par
effraction en France on garde nos
frontières ça veut dire que les demandes
de droit d'asile sont déposées ailleurs
que sur le territoire français ou dans
des points très particuliers sur nos
frontières etc et surtout un bras de fer
pour de les laisser passer consulaire
avec les pays d'où viennent ces migrants
clandestins
de loi constitutionnelle pour le moment
la proposition de loi constitutionnelle
nous ne sommes pas fous il faut soit un
référendum ou les majorités majorité des
3/5 commençant par la loi ordinaire
commençons par ce qui est le plus simple
je réponds à Julien Lecuyer qui a posé
une bonne question je pense que il pose
toujours des bonnes questions et vous
aussi mais je pense depuis le départ que
ce texte ne passera pas à l'Assemblée
sans un 49-3 pourquoi il y a deux
hypothèses ou bien le gouvernement se
déporte vers nos positions et il perdra
dans sa propre majorité des députés ou
bien
il reste les deux pieds dans le même
sabot c'est à dire qu'ils ne bougent pas
par rapport au texte qu'il a déjà ou
alors il reprend le texte issu de la
commission du Sénat mais qui est un
texte très insuffisant et alors c'est
nous qui va te rendre compte donc je ne
vois pas comment mais ce texte peut
aboutir 149-3 à l'Assemblée nationale
la formule jusqu'au bout si il y a 49,3
émotion de censure déposée par le groupe
LR à l'Assemblée nationale c'est une
possibilité que avait pointé mon
collègue bien sûr qui est le président
du groupe LR à l'Assemblée Olivier
Marleix donc ça veut dire qu'on s'y
achemine enfin pour vous on s'achemine
vers une motion de censure déposée par
elle en tout cas non je ne sais pas
parce que je veux dire
en venant sur nos positions mais il y
aura pas de minimes mais c'est pas une
question là encore de bras de fer c'est
pas une question de tout ou rien est-ce
qu'on veut oui ou non enfin régler la
question migratoire ce que je veux
simplement dire c'est qu'il y a deux
courbes qui sont liées le désordre
migratoire l'augmentation du score aux
élections du rassemblement national
Mayotte par exemple Jean-Marie Le Pen
second tour il y a un peu plus de 20 ans
en 2022 à la présidentielle il fait
moins de 12%
2022 ça fit Marine Le Pen second tour à
Mayotte près de 60%, 50% et vous pouvez
regarder ce qui se passe en Finlande en
Suède voilà au Danemark les courbes sont
liées donc est-ce que l'on résout le
problème ou on ne le résout pas on a les
solutions et moi j'invite Elisabeth
borde le gouvernement Gérald Darmanin a
reprend nos solutions jamais de voterons
un texte qui tromperait les Français qui
leur feraient penser qui leur feraient
croire qu'il y a des bonnes solutions
nous ne voterons des textes que si les
solutions sont efficaces pas question
d'avoir une 22e loi en 20 et quelques
années pour rien du tout donc venez
soulez pas la motion de censure sur ce
texte Gérard Larcher ce matin dans un
entretien à l'AFP il exclut pas non plus
la motion de censure sur le budget il
dit c'est le budget pèse par 49.3 il y
aura une possible motion de censure si
le gouvernement ne s'emploie pas
redresser les finances publiques vous
êtes d'accord avec ça bien sûr je pense
il parle d'accidentologie d'un risque on
en parlait ensemble il y a quelques
jours je vais parler un accident je lui
disais que l'automne je l'avais indiqué
la première ministre d'ailleurs que
l'automne pourrait être le moment des
accidents puisque le gouvernement devra
utiliser une dizaine de 49,3 sur le
budget le budget sera compliqué on a
sauvé d'extrême justesse la notation
avec Thunder ce qui nous a pas d'écoté
avant nous avait des côtés mais on est
dans une situation absolument terrible
3000 milliards et les taux et les taux
qui sont peut se passer du 49-3 sur le
budget vous êtes prêt à le voter vous le
budget les républicains
vous pourriez le voter la dernière fois
on l'a pas voté la dernière fois parce
que heureusement d'ailleurs puisque
regardez on est à 3000 milliards de net
et aujourd'hui on creuse des déficits on
augmente la dette voilà donc là vous
dites à Gabriel Attal à Bruno Le Maire à
Elizabeth trouvant un budget commun mais
en tout cas nous en première lecture au
Sénat on a voté des budgets simplement à
l'Assemblée il le détricote et qu'on ne
le vote pas mais on fera des
propositions bien sûr ceci dit il va y
avoir une loi de programmation des
finances publiques et on verra bien ce
que le gouvernement prévoit simplement
je redis au téléspectateur en essayant
d'être le plus simple possible on a
refusé la trajectoire du gouvernement
qui nous proposait une trajectoire de
dépense jusqu'à 2027 c'était en décembre
on l'a refusait parce que c'était trop
mou en termes d'économie il y avait trop
peu d'économies et 5 mois après le
gouvernement fait la même chose pour
l'envoyer à Bruxelles et qu'est-ce qu'on
voit en 5 mois il y a 30 milliards de
plus de dépenses supplémentaires d'ici à
2027 pour être précis 12 milliards de
plus de coût de la dette parce que les
taux d'intérêt ont augmenté et 18
milliards de dépenses tant que c'est
faux chaque semaine chaque semaine il y
a des milliards qui s'envolent quand
Bruno Le Maire dit c'est à l'heure
auprès mais c'est faux c'est faux les
dépenses ordinaires de l'État continuent
en dehors du covid ou de toute crise a
augmenté mais vous tendez la main
exécuter sur le budget vous dites chiche
pour reprendre le mot de Gérardin
maintenant nous travaillons travaillons
sur un texte commun sur le budget 2024
j'ai tenté de vous dire je me suis mal
exprimé que ma boussole c'était parce
que propose au Gouvernement email Macron
c'était pas la politique proposition et
vous allez voir si les actes
être utile au pays donc on va essayer
avec le budget que qui nous sera donné
de le modifier mais mais si on reprend
pas vos propositions 49-3 notions de
changer bien sûr on va dans le mur on va
dans le mur et on y va très rapidement
et en klaxonnant on sera le dernier pays
d'Europe 27e à atteindre les critères
notamment des 3% des visites et je pense
que à l'heure actuelle on ne les
atteindra pas la France est le pays
d'Europe actuellement le plus mal géré
la Grèce l'Espagne Portugal - Italie on
fait des efforts que nous avons été pour
le moment incapable de faire dans ce
contexte là Bruno retaillod est-ce que
Elisabeth borne peut tenir est-ce qu'un
remaniement n'est pas nécessaire
ça c'est un problème de président de la
République je pense que c'est pas le
remaniement c'est le cap je pense qu'il
a sans doute pas intérêt à changer de
Première ministre aujourd'hui alors
qu'il faudra endosser une dizaine de
49,3 à l'automne je pense qu'il usera
jusqu'au bout mais le premier il est pas
là le problème c'est que ce quinquennat
est malnet voilà Emmanuel Macron n'a pas
fait campagne il a été servi il fait
campagne en ce moment j'allais dire non
mais c'est au moment quand on est dans
une démocratie le moment de la campagne
c'est un moment de vérité on fait
campagne pour présenter un projet il n'a
pas fait campagne donc on ne sait pas
bien quel est son projet pas de campagne
pas de mandat claire pas de mandat
claire du coup un élu sans cape sans
boussole il a du coup et c'est l'unique
raison il n'a pas eu la majorité absolue
à l'Assemblée nationale parce qu'il a
refusé cette règle démocratique parce
qu'il y a eu un flou et on sent bien que
vous souvenez le soir de son élection
second tour un discours totalement plat
pas de souffle pas d'élan pas d'élan et
et il n’y a pas de cap donc il nous faut
un cap les Français veulent savoir voilà
il a Emmanuel Macron
des 100 jours de le 17 avril on sent
qu'il a repris son bâton de pèlerin il
est il est partout à la fois il est ce
dans les dans les territoires pour il
distribue les millions voir les voir les
milliards on sent qu'il a repris il a
repris une campagne électorale vous
pouvez pas dire à l'heure actuelle tu ne
fais rien non mais un exercice la
démocratie c'est le suffrage universel
le suffrage universel ce sont des
élections il y a des règles pour la
sélection quand un élu quand un
prétendant soit de se faire élire la
moindre des choses c'est d'exposer une
vision c'est d'avoir de faire une
campagne d'avoir pour avoir un mandat
clair pour pouvoir réformer pour pouvoir
ensuite agir et il s'est lié Jupiter est
devenu Gulliver il s'est enchaîné il
s'est enchaîné par des fils qui tiennent
à ce comportement là et qui tiennent
aussi ou en même temps
c'est que depuis qu'on a mis sur la
table ces propositions sur l'immigration
depuis que nous avons été d'abord unis
et ensemble à le foncier en faisant des
propositions et bien nous avons fait
l'actualité politique le paysage
politique c'est structuré autour de ses
propositions le rassemblement national
et a réagi Renaissance y a réagi et
aujourd'hui la question c'est la
question du rapport de la majorité
relative à LR donc j'en tire moi en tout
cas une conséquence pour ma famille
politique
urgence c'est pas désigner un candidat
pour 2024
urgence c'est de refonder l'urgence ce
sont les idées c'est à partir des idées
que les Français
pourront nous écouter ça tombe bien à
vous lancer vos états généraux samedi
alors j'ai regardé j'ai regardé une
transition le jardin j'ai regardé le
programme
on doit passer une heure et demie au
total là sur ou la droite doit-elle
aller alors j'allais dire c'est un peu
court pour pour l'instant c'est le début
j'osais est-ce qu'il va y avoir du
boulot
c'est le début des États généraux qui
auront un parcours de 6 mois avec un
certain nombre de rendez-vous dans
chaque département dans chaque
fédération pour mettre à même justement
nos adhérents nos sympathisants de nous
dire ce qu'ils veulent de nous moi j'ai
une conviction puisque je l'avais dit
pendant la campagne vous aviez vite tout
changer il faut tout changer voire même
le nom du parti exactement je pensais
toujours oui mais j'observe que Eric
Ciotti d'ailleurs dans les colonnes du
Parisien dimanche dernier a repris une
demi-idée il a dit mais finalement c'est
vrai l'urgence ce que il voulait
désigner le candidat pour 2027 en 2023
l'urgence c'est pas c'est désignation
c'est pas l'incarnation c'est la
refondation voilà et c'est vrai que
c'est c'est l'urgence on a perdu 10
millions d'électeurs en un peu plus de
15 ans
est-ce que c'est les électeurs qui sont
trompés ou est-ce que c'est nous j'ai
plutôt tendance à penser que c'est nous
qui nous sommes trompés et je crois que
si on a perdu ses électeurs c'est pas
parce que la droite a été pas
suffisamment à gauche c'est au contraire
ce qui n'a pas assumé ces convictions et
nous les avons déboussolé donc je pense
que c'est un moment où on doit retracer
une ligne faire des propositions et sans
doute faire un référendum interne et ça
tranchera
si nos militants sont d'accord avec ce
que nous allons leur proposer on doit
répondre à la question aujourd'hui de
quoi la droite est-elle le nom quelle
qu'il y a comme contenu interne bien sûr
comme je dis non mais comme chez
renaissance pour dire une fois un accord
de gouvernement est-ce que ça c'est un
référendum que vous pourriez envisager
j'en connais un résultat mais d'abord
essayons de régler la question du
contenu de la ligne des propositions et
ensuite une fois que c'est tranché par
référendum c'est la démocratie interne
les chapeaux à plumes les uns les autres
qui cherchent parfois la dissonance
devront s'y rallier c'est important
aussi en termes de discipline collective
des gens comme
d'autres je pense que on peut avoir des
sensibilités ça je l'accepte
parfaitement mais pas être
systématiquement en opposition mais
d'ailleurs j'observe que c'est pas le
cas d'ailleurs je pense que on a
retrouvé une forme d'unité vous aurez
aussi remarqué que il y a quelques jours
lorsque le fameux petit groupe liotte a
déposé sa motion de censure aucun député
LR ne l'avait
donc c'est un bon signe je trouve
dernière question Julien oui peut-être
sur les sénatoriales ou à sur Paris on
est entre Dallas et dynastie j'ai un de
liste élèves qui s'affrontent c'est le
mené par Caroline Dumas soutenu par
Rachida datium
et celle de l'euro député Agnès est
evraine on est passé proche de la
catastrophe avec un recours qui a été
déposé je vous passe tous les tous les
détails normalement ça devait être enfin
résolu par une commission d'investiture
qui n'a pas encore eu lieu vous dites là
à l'heure actuelle à tous ces gens
altofeu arrêtons bien sûr monsieur il
faut absolument apaiser moi je salue
d'ailleurs le sens de la responsabilité
de Catherine Dumas puisque le recours a
été a été retiré il faut l'apaisement
vous savez Paris il y a une tradition il
y a toujours une division
si loin que remonte ma mémoire donc moi
qui suis provincial j'observe ça avec
beaucoup de modestie beaucoup de recul
j'attends de voir que ce que tout ça va
donner bon j'espère que nous aurons
quatre sénateurs et sénatrices à la
rentrée prochaine ce matin à la FP qui
ne sera candidat à la présidence vous
serez candidat ou à votre succession à
la tête du groupe
je pense que notre tandem fonctionne
bien on a été élu lui réélu en 2014 moi
élu président de groupe en 2014 à
l'époque vous voyez je pouvais pas faire
un plateau sans qu'on me demande quelle
est l'utilité du Sénat est-ce que le
Sénat c'est pas une anomalie
démocratique et jamais plus de cette
question donc je pense qu'il y a il y a
un travail qui a été fait en premier
lieu par Gérard Larcher moi je l'ai
accompagné parce que on est le groupe
politique central si on veut un sénat
qui tienne debout qui dégage des
majorités qui dégagent des lignes très
très claires qui soit un vrai
contre-pouvoir il faut aussi un groupe
vous voyez majoritaire qui tiennent
debout je pense que c'est le cas on l'a
montré sur la retraite dans les moments
difficiles on a tenu le choc et moi je
me félicite que Gérard Larcher qui
incarne vraiment notre institution
puisse se représenter en septembre
prochain et vous représentez également
merci beaucoup merci Bruno retaille
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin elle a
une de la Voix du Nord pollution à
l'ozone restriction irritation